- A couple of years ago,
I visited Silicon Valley in California
and there I met with a venture capitalist
and we were talking about
some great startup ideas,
what the market was doing.
And this person shared
that every now and then
there will be a startup
approaching this VC firm
and pitching an idea about
a data analytics tool.
And in the end of the day,
it would turn out that what
these people were building
was pretty much just a new
version of Excel pivot tables.
So this little anecdote
hopefully makes clear
that pivot tables in Excel
are really, extremely powerful.
They are a tool
that you will be expected
to definitely master
in any consulting role,
for sure in the big MBB
strategy consulting firms
like McKinsey, BCG and Bain.
So in this video, I'm going
to talk exactly about that.
And this is pivot tables in Excel.
So welcome to a new coffee
break here on my channel,
Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich, and on my channel,
I want to help you to become successful
in the first years of your career.
And to help you follow
along in this video,
I will offer the data set in Excel
that we use to build this,
including the tables,
the results of this video,
as a donor for you, of course, for free.
You can access this via the
link in the video description.
Check it out to get the data set,
and then follow along
while I show you the things
here in this video.
Let's start by looking at the data set
that will serve as the
basis for your pivot table.
And you can imagine this to
be the dataset of a retailer.
So data like that in such
a simple, normalized format
you can commonly obtain as an export
from all your ERP or
business information systems.
What we have here is in the
first column, the stores.
So as you can see here,
this company has different
stores that it operates.
Every store has their own ID
that is associated to the store,
and then there are lots of sales reps.
So here we just have the ID of the reps.
You can see that there are, apparently,
about 154 sales reps, like that.
And then the data is
breaking down by month.
So you have all the months here first,
and the numeric value from one to 11.
So as you can see here,
this is just data from
January to November.
And then you can see both the net revenue
that here was generated and also the cost.
So the cost of goods sold, COGS.
Now let's include a pivot table.
And I'll just highlight
it here, the whole table.
And now to access pivot tables,
you click here on insert and
then you click on pivot tables
and then you can just go
here on from table range.
And if you click on that,
it asks first for the table range
and here it already then
pre-selects the range
that was selected before.
So as you can see,
this is exactly the
table that we have here
until the end here of the sheet.
And then it asks where this
is supposed to be inserted.
So do you wanna have it on a new worksheet
or on an existing worksheet?
You can just leave it as it,
and then if you click okay
you can see that here
it inserted a new tab.
And let's maybe just call it pivot table
here in the bottom.
Now you can see it looks
something like this
and here on the right,
you have all the different
variables here of the table.
So for this to work properly,
it's important that each
column has a column header.
So on the first row of each
column there needs to be,
yeah, some header, some name.
If this is missing,
you might get an error.
And also here, all the
different variables.
So here for New York, for instance,
in every row, it needs to repeat New York.
So what doesn't work is that
maybe only in until here,
only maybe in the first you have New York
and then you leave all this
empty, this doesn't work.
This will give you errors.
This will hinder how
your pivot table works.
You can see that right now,
the pivot table is just an
empty field pretty much,
but here on the right,
you have these four key fields, right?
You have filters, you have columns,
you have rows and you have values.
So let's start here
with the values bucket.
The idea is now that you
can just drag and drop
these variables in these four areas here.
So let's start with the net revenues.
So let's imagine here
in values, net revenue.
We just want to have the number.
And this now just gives me
the total revenue number
in the table.
And we can just verify that.
So if I just highlight all of that,
we can see it here on the bottom.
The sum of this is 6.7998,
and so on, yeah, million Euro,
which is exactly the number
that we have in here.
Of course, this is not so insightful yet.
So maybe let's now split it up
by different variables, right?
And we can do that here in the rows.
And maybe first one to go
for would be the stores.
Maybe we wanna see how now the
revenue breaks down by store.
And we can just do that by
dragging and dropping here
the store name to the rows.
And now, as you can see,
maybe let me zoom in here a little bit,
as you can see now, it shows
me the revenues by store.
Of course, we can also format this here
as an accounting number.
And this, of course, is not great, right,
because now it gives you
already some basic data
which, of course, you could
also generate from this table
but it will take you some time, right?
It would take you like,
and of course, different
ways of doing that,
but it's not that, really.
Usually the pivot tables are the best ways
to really create some aggregated data,
aggregated things that
you can access here.
Now, next, you can use more
than one variable in the row.
So let's say we want to
break up the revenue data
of the stores also by months.
And we can just then drag as
an additional variable here,
the months in here.
All right, so now you can see
here January, February, March.
Of course, instead of that,
we can also just drag and drop here
this other variable, which
just gives the numbers.
And surely like this,
probably not that helpful,
so let's take out here the
names and just the numbers,
or the other way.
Of course, we can also access both.
Let's maybe stick with the names for now.
And now you can see that
it's breaking up the data
by these variables.
You can see that here I can
collapse and expand this
to then just get the totals.
If I right click, I can
also access this menu
and, for instance, say
collapse entire field, right,
to collapse them all or then
also expand entire field
to get them all again.
Now let's also look at some
other variables, right?
I can pretty much nest in here
as many variables as I want.
Maybe I wanna also look at the sales reps.
And now we can break up
the revenue by store,
by months and by sales reps.
Maybe let's take out the months again,
just to have the stores
and the sales reps.
The order matters, right?
If I turn it around,
if I first start with the sales reps
and then with the store name,
you can see that it looks like this.
So maybe not that
interesting, but of course,
you can also just use
little exercises like this
just to get a better feel for the data.
So maybe you are asking yourself
is one sales rep only working in one store
or is one sales rep maybe also
working in different stores?
In more than one store, right?
And if we look at that,
we can see that for each
of these sales reps,
there's always only one store listed.
So if ones sales rep ID would,
it would be apparent, would
show up in more than one stores,
you would have here different rows
with different stores
nested under the sales rep,
which is not the case here.
And now maybe you want to show the months
but not here in the rows, but
maybe in the columns, right?
So this is an additional field
that you have available here.
So if we just take the months
and I just drag it here
in the columns field,
what you can see is that
instead of breaking the
fields down here in the rows,
I can just show the values
here in the columns,
which, of course, makes a lot
of sense for continuous data,
like time data.
So for other variables,
if we want to put the sales
reps here in the columns,
this of course gives me a result, right?
And I can see now all the
sales reps by stores like that.
But of course, that's not
really intuitive to read.
So for this, usually you will
rather go with the columns.
And of course, now I can also do this here
on the monthly data, as
we can see right here,
and then have the stores
breaken down by the sales reps
and then those data here in the columns.
Last but least,
there's the filter bucket
where you can insert filters.
So let's say we wanna show this data
but not for all the sales reps,
but only for some sales reps.
So I can now drag such a variable,
for instance, here the sales
rep IDs into the filters.
Now you can see that
it added here this row
where I can now click on that.
And I'll select that.
Maybe I just wanna look at this
maybe just for the sales
rep with the ID number one.
And that's apparently a sales rep
that maybe isn't with the company anymore,
so let's pick another one,
maybe with the sales rep number five.
And here we can see this person
only worked in the store,
New York, in April and July.
Of course, you can also go
and select multiple items
by selecting several sales reps,
just here, randomly select some
and then we can get all the data for that.
Of course, I can do this with
other variables, as well.
Let's take that out and maybe let's say
that I only wanna show,
maybe let's take that out again,
I wanna show the revenue
data for the stores,
but not for all months,
but only for some months, right?
So I can go in here and
now just look at the number
for January or for February, right?
Or maybe I wanna show
it for January to March.
What is also often handy
is that you cannot only report
on the sum of a variable,
like the revenue,
but sometimes you also wanna look into
some other types of reports here, right?
So then you right click
on a variable here,
like the sum of the revenue.
You click on value field settings,
and now you can see that you can report
all different types of things.
So count, average, max, min,
product and so on and so forth.
So I think in this instance,
this doesn't make too much sense.
What we could, for instance,
maybe do is look at the max.
And now it reports the
highest revenue figure
that it finds for the store and the table.
And if you remember how
the table is set up,
probably what this would mean is that
this number represents the
highest monthly revenue
that one sales rep created in this store.
So again, this depends a bit on how here
the base table is set up.
Often the sum, though,
will be the go-to format
that you want to go for, indeed.
Now let's look into some
layout-ing considerations.
So maybe this example, again,
where you had the stores
and then the month,
not in the filters, but here in the rows.
So of course, while this is a great view
sometimes you also want to have
such a data set as an output
than in a normalized table format,
because we can see here
that now the column A
contains mixed information, right?
It contains both the name of the store
and also the ID of the month,
which is not always favorable
if then you want to do some
other things with the data.
So what you can do to fix it is
right click here on the table
and then go on pivot table options.
And then under display,
you find here the option
classical pivot table layout,
enables dragging of fields and so on.
So usually I like to have this activated
because what this is doing,
it separates all the different information
in different columns,
which is what you need,
and then in the end
with such a pivot table
you want to create a
normalized table format again,
which can be helpful, for instance,
with building dashboards.
So if you watch my other video
on creating dashboards in Excel,
you know what I'm talking about.
I will link it somewhere above here.
This technique is really
helpful to, for instance,
then with some formulas and so on
build some quite dynamic dashboards.
Check out the video if you
wanna learn more about that.
You can also do things like deleting
or taking out here the subtotals.
So we can see that here we have
the subtotal for the store name.
We can take it out, of course,
inserting again, if we want.
And then, again,
for the sake of having
normalized, clean tables,
often what you need to do is
that you want to repeat
the labeling, right?
So you don't want the store name
only to appear in the first row,
but you want it to appear in all the rows,
again, in order to have a
nice, normalized table format.
So if you wanna do that,
just here right click,
click field settings,
and then you can do
here in layout and print
to go on repeat item labels.
You need to tick the check mark
and then you will have it
repeated throughout the table.
Again, you might want then also to
take out the subtotal again
to have a very clean,
normalized table to work with.
So let's continue
and let's say we might want
to do some more, right?
We not only want to work
here with the revenue data,
but we also wanna show
some margin information
by store and by month,
or maybe let's not do it by
month, but by sales rep, right?
So we might want to compare
the different margins
that the sales reps have available here.
So let's take out the
filters to show all the reps
in all the stores.
And, of course,
the variable that we have
available here are the cost.
So I can now drag the cost
also here in the values area
to now show both the net
revenue and the cost.
But now one thing,
maybe let's start first
without the reps to simplify,
now here have the revenue
and the cost data.
One thing that, of course,
typically you would like to do
is you would now take the
revenue and subtract the cost
in order to get to the margin,
to the gross margin.
The problem is that
you cannot really work
like this with pivot tables
because if you just copy that over,
as you can see, it does
not really then go here
and then adjust the formula accordingly.
So that doesn't work.
There are some other ways to
like, you know, make it work.
You know, let's not go too much into that.
Of course, another alternative would be
you can just take the table
and you can copy just the values, right?
So you can copy the values
and then, of course,
you just have the data you
have extracted next to you.
You can, of course, also format this
in an accounting format.
And then, of course, you
can do whatever you like.
So you can do the same calculations,
and then, of course, also the
style of working with formulas
does work to make that work.
But that's also not the real
way how these pivot tables
are intended to work because, of course,
now if you change anything here,
this doesn't adjust automatically.
But sometimes this can be a little hack
to a very quick and straightforward way
to do your own calculations.
So instead, what you can do
to really make this work in pivot tables
is to use something that is
called calculated fields, right?
So if you here click on
the pivot table analyze,
you need to highlight the pivot
table for this to show up,
you go on fields, items and sets,
you go on calculated fields.
Now you can just create
your own additional fields.
So let's say we want to
have the gross margin
and let's first start
in absolute, so in Euro.
And in order to that here,
it gives me all the fields
that are loaded into the pivot table
that I can now work with.
And of course, the margin
is the net revenue.
So click here on insert field,
and then you can see that
it's added to the formula.
And I'll press minus and
now here, press COGS.
So cost of good sold as an additional one.
And now I add this and now you can see
that I have here the gross
margin and percent available.
And now let's do once more, right?
Let's even add an additional field.
Let's now say we want to have
the gross margin in percentage.
And, of course, this would be then
the gross margin absolute
that we just added
divided by the net revenue,
insert to now give us
this additional field.
Now we press okay.
And now you can see that
it already added that here
to the table.
Of course, here, the percentage,
we will likely want to form
it as a percentage, indeed,
to make it look like something like this.
I think this is already
first interesting analysis
to now see how different
margins of these stores
compare to each other.
And the great thing is that
as soon as you have added those variables
as calculated fields,
you can do all the things we did
with the pivot table already, right?
So you can add them to the tables,
you can then also drill down with it
with all the other additional variables.
So maybe, you know,
let's just look at the percentage figures,
then we probably also don't
need the COGS anymore.
Let's say we want to break this down
by the different sales reps.
So here by the different
sales reps of the stores
so we can see what their revenue is.
We can see what their margin is,
the non-average they created.
Maybe we don't need the stores,
we just have the sales reps here.
And, of course, you can also do things
like sorting this whole
thing by the margin.
So here, let's sort by the
margin from largest to smallest.
And, of course, here now we
have some funny data in here.
So sales reps who probably
didn't do a lot of revenue,
maybe just were some assistants
working there for a couple of days,
but here we can see
that there are some reps
which also more significant results.
So this person was doing more
than 30,000 Euro in revenue
and had the margin of 64%.
So there are reps like that,
that are doing quite well.
And then of course,
we can now go down to
the bottom of the table
where we have margins,
where we have reps who
are doing 60,000 Euro
and have a really low margin, right?
And this, of course, would be interesting,
conducts a basic analyses like this,
have an understanding of the data
and then to work with this in this way.
But that's another thing
that is very powerful
that you can do with pivot tables.
And this is to use them to
create dashboards in Excel,
to create dynamic dashboards in Excel.
So to make them work,
let's look at an example.
Let's maybe work with the store names.
So let's imagine you
wanna make a dashboard
that helps me to slice into
revenue and margin data
for the store.
So let's add here the
revenue and the margins.
And the first thing in order to move there
that's already pretty cool
is if you here click
on pivot table analyze,
there is the option
here to insert slicers.
All right, so you can insert slicers.
Now it asks you what type
of slicers you want to have.
So let's say we want to
have slicers for the months
and maybe also for the store names.
So let's add both of them.
And you can see that now it
added these additional panels
that you can here freely
position in your table.
And what this is doing
now just on the table
that you can now select, for instance,
this data just for January
or just for February or just for March.
So at the end of the day,
it's nothing else but filters.
You can also tick several of them,
but it's a bit of a more visual way.
And this can be then very easily
used as an input mechanism
for the dashboards that
you want to create,
because the next thing that you can do
is also to insert charts.
So if you click here on the pivot table,
pivot table analyze,
it provides you the opportunity to insert
a pivot chart, as it's called.
And maybe let's just here
go for the standard clustered columns.
So here by store,
it gives me the net revenue
and the gross margin.
Of course, you can go with
any other chart, as well.
And it's a special type of chart
that automatically adjusts the content
to all the things we have
shown here in the pivot table,
because now what you can do is that
if you here now change this,
it automatically changes all the contents
of your stores as well.
And of course you can
highlight both, right?
You can say, let me just show
the data for Berlin for May
or for April or for March.
Or maybe I want to have different stores.
So Berlin, Dusseldorf and London.
And this is really the core
of how you would build dashboards.
So if you would wanna make a
great dashboard out of that,
you could now create all types
of pivot tables like that.
Often, then you do a distinct tab
where you hide all your pivot tables
and then you have an output tab
where you have all kinds
of charts like this.
And then, of course, you
can format the charts,
make them look a little bit better.
You can also format these slicers
to make them look really
cool, really great.
So I don't want to go
into detail here too much
because, of course, you
can just really go like
spend lots of time talking about this,
but then you have some
controls for the users
who can just drill down here in the data,
select the dates, select the stores.
And this is really a powerful way
on how you can enable your users to,
in a very intuitive way,
with the help of pivot tables,
drill down into your data sets.
So there are different
ways of building dashboards
with Excel pivot tables.
For sure, is one very effective of them.
Again, I have a full
playlist with Excel videos,
including one video on
how to build dashboards
without pivot tables.
Actually, in the video
that I created there,
let me know in the comments
if you would be interested
in another video
on how to build dashboards
with pivot tables.
And of course, check out the
other videos in the playlist
to learn more about Excel.
So if you have any questions on this
or other tips you want to share
on Excel or pivot tables yourself,
feel free to leave a comment
in the comment section.
Also big, big, thanks to all
the members of the channel.
Thank you for supporting the course here.
This is very much appreciated.
If you took any value
out of this video at all,
please sit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to stay
up to date on all my content
and also turn on the notification bell.
My name is Heinrich.
I do these weekly videos
every single Saturday.
See you again next week.
Until then, all the
best to you and bye-bye.